je pense qu'on peut tout faire moi avec
le corps tous les je pense qu'on a une
grande souplesse naturelle comme un ami
comme les animaux par exemple
et dès qu'il ya quelque chose vous dire
qu'on serait dit par là par le langage
presque on peut se raidir on peut on en
à sa morphologie qui s'essaie c'est
l'être profond qui ressort quand je dis
pourquoi il ya des gens qui marchent
comme ça où des gens qui marchent des
pieds en fait il ya beaucoup de choses
et là dessus moi je suis très sensible à
la halle écoute du corps des autres
aussi mais toi par exemple entre les
plantes sur un plateau tu n'arrêtes pas
de bouger oui dans la concentration
ayant moi j'ai une faculté de
concentration qui est un peu que de dire
qu'ils bougent beaucoup faire je tiens
voilà c'est c'est ma concentration à moi
c'est bon c'est ma pudeur ses mots c'est
des choses qui ressortent comme ça il ya
des gens qui ont besoin de de se
retrouver de faire le calme non moi je
n'ai besoin de rien de moi je dire
j'avais besoin de faire le propre le
vide nous pour être complètement pour
être uniquement mais c'est tout je
comprends parfaitement les gens qui se
concentre aussi je sais c'est chacun 101
chacun ses grigris pour moi toute forme
de travail dans ce métier tu ne ferais
une c'est comme une superstition presse
que si jamais on s'écoute dedans je dis
on peut
un peu plus précis jamais on s'arrête on
s'écoute il ya un moment où on est
tellement bloquée qu'on peut plus faire
un pas moi je ne crois pas cette forme
de travail là je repars aussi aux
acteurs je dis je crois pas les acteurs
sont pas je crois plutôt aux artistes
aux gens qui ont les artistes sont
sauvages sont cruels aussi je crois pas
la sensibilité des des acteurs des
escouades contraire il ya une espèce de
vision des choses comme ça qu'on se soit
gelée c'est comme des grandes peintures
de den bosch ou doute gaillacoise
douleur qui est à l'intérieur
je vois plutôt ça parce que j'ai une
espèce de sens j'aime bien la tragédie
j'ai instant sens tragique des choses
aussi j'aime bien
j'aime bien la tragédie en même temps
mais avec le métier est ce qu'il n'ya
pas un danger tout même d'accueil un
certain tiquer certains trucs d'acteurs
certainement bien sûr mais je veux dire
que les pour moi je pense pas qu'ils
aient des dirigeants nazis y en a
certainement moi même entièrement je
suis un tic maintenant si puisqu'à force
puisqu'on est dans une situation d'être
regardés et on peut s'apercevoir si
jamais on détaille bien que je peux être
bourré de tics mais pour moi c'est
anecdotique c'est c'est pas c'est pas
dans ce moi ça ne me dérange pas parce
que je sais que le peuple le sol fa le
seul art que j'ai c'est de ces la
liberté c'est la disponibilité
[Musique]